شكرا جزيلا لك وسيله اهلا بكم مشاهدينا
الى هذه النافذه الجديده للتحليل العسكري
لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها
نستضيف كالعاده المحلل العسكري اللواء
فايز الدويري ونتابع اخر تطورات المشهد
ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه مع سلام
خضر تفضلي سلام شكرا ليلى اذا في اليوم
الث3 للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه هناك
تطورات متسارعه ومتلاحقة
نبدا من المنطقه الجنوبيه التي تشهد
تطورات متسارعه جدا ومتلاحقة
ق الجنوبيه طبعا اسرائيل وبحسب المعلومات
الميدانيه اثناء توغلها الى المنطقه ال
الجنوبيه نفذت وتنفذ اليوم هناك غارات
وقصف اسرائيلي مكثف على المنطقه الشرقيه
المحاذيه للحدود مع اسرائيل هذه التطورات
تاتي بعد ان دفعت اسرائيل بلواء سادس الى
منطقه خان يونس لينضم الى الالويه الخمسه
التي تقاتل هناك وبالتالي هناك سته الويه
الان تتولى المنطقه
الجنوبيه الهجوم على مدينه خانيونس
الاسرائيلي طبعا تم من
عده محاور هناك قوه توغلت من وسط القطاع
وبطبيعه الحال القوات الاكبر توغلت من
المنطقه الشماليه هناك استهدافات وهناك
اشتباكات تصفها اسرائيل بنفسها بانها
الاكثر ضراوه و القسام يقولون انهم اوقعوا
قتل بين في صفوف الاسرائيليين اليوم نتوجه
الى الوسط في الوسط اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه وسع عملياته العسكريه في تلك المناطق
يستهدف بال بال بشكل كبير ال المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وهي مخيمات او ما
تسمى بالمخيمات في المدينه طبعا تشهد هذه
الجبهه قتالا عنيفا ومحاولات اسرائيليه
للتوغل الى مخيم البريج حتى الان هناك
مقاومه شديده ومستمره من قبل القسام وباقي
الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وتبقى منطقه جحر الديك ايضا
منطقه اشتباك رغم انها من اولى المناطق
التي دخلتها اسرائيل قبل نحو شهرين او
اكثر ببضعه ايام عندما بدات العمليه
البريه هناك ك ايضا استهدافات لتجمعات
لجنود الاحتلال في المنطقه الوسطى او في
الق يعني في المحافظه الوسطى في قطاع غزه
تحديدا قرب شرق وجنوب شرق مخيم البريش حيث
الاشتباكات الاعنف بالعوده الى المنطقه
الشماليه ايضا لا تزال هناك اشتباكات على
اكثر من محور رغم انها اسرائيل تكرر على
سبيل المثال قبل بضعه ايام قال وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي انهم سيطروا على منطقه
جباليا وعلى منطقه الشجاعيه بشكل كامل
اليوم هناك اشتباكات تقول اسرائيل انها
قويه جدا في حي التفاح على سبيل المثال
وفي حي الدرج هذه الاحياء هي محاذ عند او
هي الاحياء هي هي هذه الاحياء هي مداخل
مدينه غزه بمعنى اخر وهناك دبابات
اسرائيليه في بعض الشوارع الداخليه
للمدينه بمعنى اخر يفترض من حيث الشكل ان
تكون هذه المناطق قد امنت امنتها القوات
الاسرائيليه قبل ان تتوغل ولكن من الواضح
ان ظهر هذه القوات المتوغلة
من نفق ولكن لم يعطي مزيد من التفاصيل
وحتى انه لم يبث الصورا تؤكد هذه
المعلومات ليلى هذه بطريقه مختصره ما امكن
ابرز التطورات في قطاع غزه اليوم المزيد
معك واللواء الدويري شكرا جزيلا لك سلام
طبعا اللواء فايز ربما ننطلق من هذه
النقطه الحسابات الاسرائيليه الخاطئه في
التوغل يعني هي مناطق يفترض ان تكون
امنتها كما قالت سلام للتو وفيها كل
المعدات والاليات ولكن رغم
ذلك تواجه مقاومه شرسه اولا طبيعه المعركه
هذه المعركه هي ليست حرب تقليديه بين جيش
وجيش في الحروب التقليديه اذا ما كانت
حققت احد الطرفي الصراع اهداف المرحله
يكون الجيش الاخر قد انسحب واخلى هذه
المنطقه نحن دخلنا في حرب ما يطلق عل
الجوريلا وفير دخلنا في حرب لا اقول
العصابات لانه كلمه غير جميله في اللغه
العربيه انما بديلها الحرب غير اللام
متناظره او الغير متناظره اي بين جيش
النظامي حسب الاسس التنظيميه المعتمده
عالميا وهذا الجيش هو رقم 18 من حيث القوه
والرقم اربعه من حيث استخدامه واعتماده
على التكنولوجيا لكن هو لا يقاتل جيوش هو
يقاتل افراد يقاتل تنظيمات لها تنظيمها
الخاص لها طريقتها الخاصه في اداره
المعركه لكن في هذه الحاله هناك ثلاثه
مرتكزات اضافيه ليست عمليات قتال بين جيش
وجماعات
مدربه المرتكز الاول المنطقه
مبنيه المنطقه منطقه منطقه مباني اكيد
وبالتالي الدخ القتال داخل المناطق
المبنيه لو كان قتالا داخل مناطق مفتوحه
الشبه الغالبه قتال في المناطق
المبنيه الامر الاخر المقاتل ليس فوق
الارض المقاتل تحت الارض في
الانفاق المقاربه الثالثه ان هذا هذا
المقاتل ليس كاي مقاتل لا هذا المقاتل
لديه تربيه خاصه تم تنشئته ضمن
ضوابط تستند الى
العقيده تستند الى المفهوم الوطني الصحيح
وبالتالي تم تم اعداده عقديا تم اعداده
مهاريا بدنيا العمل كمنفرد العمل في
مجموعه لغايه ثلاث العمل في مجموعه الى
غايه خمسه وكان اكبر استخدام مجموعه
متكامله 25 فرد يضاف الى ذلك طريقه اداره
المعركه المرتكز الاخير طريقه اداره
المعركه هي تدخل في ثلا يعني في اكثر من
اتجاه في اداره المعركه اولا قوات الصد
وهذه القوات تعتمد
مقاربه سمكه الصحراء الظهور في الوقت
المناسب والانسحاب تؤدي المهمه
وتختفي ولكن تحت مفهوم الترويع والصدمه
اذا نحن امام نوع جديد من المفاهيم
والمصطلحات الع والمفترض ان هذا الجيش
يكون قد خبر هذا في مواجهته السابقه ما
الذي يختلف في هذه المواجه ر ذلك لم لم
يستفد من تجاربه حتى لم يستفد من عام 2086
هو ودخل جزئيا في بيئه مشابهه عندما حربه
على حزب الله لكن لم تكن لا بهذه الكثافه
ولا بهذه الاطار الزمني الفضفاض ولا في
حجم القوه وبالتالي رغم ذلك هو لا يزل يصر
على انه قادر على تحقيق الاهداف وهذا يخضع
ل اعتبارات اخرى التناقضات ما بين القاده
العسكريين والقاده السياسيين القياده
السياسيه تجبر العسكريين على بقيه التحرك
وبالتالي انا تحدثت عن عن اشكال من العمل
المعركه
التصادميه جميعها تقع في اطار المعركه
الصفريه ومن ثم معركه الالتحام المباشر
ومن ثم معركه العمل خلف خطوط العدو هنا
خلف خطوط العدو تقع داخل قطاع غزه عندما
نتحدث عن جحر الديك هذه تعتبر بناء على
عمق المنطقه العمل خلف خطوط العدو واشارت
الها سلام عندما قالت ان ظهر القوات
المهاجمه اصبح مكشوفا فبالتالي هذا النوع
من العمليات ادارته ليست سهله التدريب
عليه ليس سهل تحقيق النتائج ليس سهل خاصه
ضد عدو متفوق ولكن اذا توفرت الاراده مع
الامكانات رغم تواضعها وتوظيفها بالصوره
المثاليه تكون النتيجه كما شاهدنا ونشاهد
ا ولكن هناك جزئيه ايضا ربما يعني كانت
لافته هو تقرير في الواقع لصحيفه الول
ستريت جورنال ومهم جدا ان نستعرضه
هذا التقرير يقول ان غاره جويه اسرائيليه
على مخيم جباليه في قطاع
غزه في
الحدي من شهر اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي
قتلت احد افراد حماس لكنها ادت الى مقتل
ايضا عشرات المدنيين كذلك لنتابع صور من
هذه
الحادثه التي تحدث عنها تحقيق الوول ستريت
جورنال يقول ان اسرائيل قررت عدم تحذير
المدنيين في المنطقه من غزه من من غاره
جويه وشيكا عبر رسائل هاتفيه كما تفعل
عاده التحقيق ايضا اشار الى كذلك اشار
التحقيق الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي القى على
الاقل اثنتين من اكبر القنابل في ترسانته
بدلا من استخدام ذخائر اصغر حجما اذا هذا
يعني بصراحه اللواء فايز هذا خبر يستحق ان
نتوقف عليه لعده اسباب اولا التوقيت يعني
هذا يوم السابق للحرب البريه البريه
التوقيت
31 اكتوبر وبعدين هناك نقطه اخرى هذا
الحجم وهذه الغاره النوع يعني لماذا
استخدمتها اسرائيل هل كان هل كانت تستطيع
ان تحقق الهدف نفسه كما تقول الستر دعيني
دعيني استخدم المقاربه العربيه عندما عربي
يجيب على سؤال وتكون الساعه في وقت متاخر
يقول له صباح الخير اذا اذا سمحت لي خلينا
ننظر الصور اللي نشرتها الول ستريت جورنال
هي المنطقه نفسها هذه سحد ض هذه قبل وبعد
نعم دعيني اقول عندما يطرح سؤال نعم او
يتم الاعلان عن شيء ولا يكون مقنعا فعاده
في الثقافه العربيه في بعض المناطق نقول
تكون مع شرو مع غروب الشمس بنقول له صباح
الخير يعني انت
تحدثت متاخر و معلومتك قديمه وانا
بقول الجورنال صباح الخير لماذا هو استخدم
جي بي يو 3 وزنها 2026 باوند استخدم منها
قذيفتين نس امي 84 نفس الوزن نفس
المواصفات انما المسميات مختلفه وهي يعني
هذه تستخدم بشكل مستمر هذه
القنابل اطلق عليها هي تصنيع شركه يعني
التعديل الاخير عليها اصبح اسمها جيدان
اول ما اول ما استخدمت في عاصفه الصحراء
وكانت هي غير موجهه قنابل الاسقاط جنرال
بيربوس الاسقاط الحر وزنها 2026
باوند منها انواع متدرجه جي بي يو
3 جي بييو 31 في بي جي بييو 3
2 بي او بي 2 بي 3 باوزان مختلفه وهي هناك
قذائف مكافئه لها ام كي 84 ام كي 82 ام كي
83 وبالتالي استخدم المئات من هذه القنابل
مستشفى المداني ما انا انا تحليلي الشخصي
ولم يصدر تقرير واستخدمت الام كي 84 هل
تعلم ما هو الفرق بين اي المقذوف 26
باوند 26 باوند وبالتالي اذا هذا هذا هذه
استخدمت لا لا لا يصدر تقريرا يشير على
انهم اخلاقي وانساني والحفره التي سببتها
ولكن تقول الوول ستريت جورنال تبلغ 40 قدم
عرضها يعني هل هذا مثلا امر كان يتطلب
تقول الوول ستريت جورنال انه ارادت ان
تستهدف احد قاده حماس ولم تنذر لانها كان
لديها معلومات ان هناك احد قاده حماس في
المنطقه لم تبلغ كما اشرت على الرسائل
النصيه لاخلاء المنطقه من اجل ان لا تصل
هذه الرساله لذا القائد او لاي شخص لديه
وسيله اتصال فضحت بالمنطقه بمن فيها من
اجل اصطياد هذا القائد اذا دعني اقول هذه
الذخيره لا تتناسب مع الهدف وهذه هي احد
لا اخلاق
الحرب ان ان تستخدمي ذخائر لا تتناسب مع
الاهداف معظم الذخائر عذرا معظم الذخائر
الاسرائيليه التي استخدمت هل هي استخدمت
ضد المقاتلين ام ضد المجتمع المدني اذا هي
كلها سلسله من الجرائم والول ستريت جورنال
لم تقدم الكثير وبالنسبه لي كمحلل لا
اشكرها لا يعني انت يعني وضحت الرساله
عندما قلت صباح الخير ولكن في نقطه ان
تقوم الول ستريت جورنال نشر هذه المعلومه
الان ايضا فيها رساله هل هذا يدل على
علاقه الان تريد او رساله تريد الاداره
الامريكيه ان ترسلها ايضا لاسرا هذا موضوع
اخر هناك خلاف ما بين البيت الابيض وما
بين نتنياهو والان هناك اشارات وايماءات
كل عده ايام تظهر اشاره كان قبل عده ايام
طلب اسرائيلي بطلب المزيد من
طائرات الاباتشي وتم رفضه كان هنا في نفس
الوقت وافقوا على ارسال السبير بارتس
لتصليح اعاده بناء دبابات الميركافا يقابل
ذلك الان هم عند هذا التصريح كانه يقول
لهم هناك فجوه بينا وبينكم مطالبنا واضحه
حول نوع الذخائر واطار الحرب ومده الحرب
عليكم الامتثال او الالتقاء في نقطه وسطيه
ولا يتحدث نتنياهو بانه سيقلب كل حجر في
غزه من اجل تحقيق اهداف لا يمكن تحقيقها
ولكنه يشير ايضا الى انه كان يمكن ان
يستخدم يعني قنبله اخرى هل المال هنا ايضا
الماد يعني هذا هذا تكلفه عاليه جدا هل في
هذا ايضا اشاره نعم كان هناك اشاره سابقه
ق حتى قبل حوالي شهر انه الاداره
الامريكيه نصحت بتقديم صواريخ منيار 7 70
ملم لاستخدامها بدل الصواريخ الاخرى لانه
هذا ثمنه تقريبا ب الا الدولارات وذاك
بمئات الالاف من الدولارات من المقاربه
اعتبرت التغليف الخارجي انساني والحقيقه
الداخليه مشكله اقتصاديه ولذلك تقرير الول
ستريت جورنال مهم جدا ايضا لمناقشته اشكرك
جزيلا لواء فايز دويري واشكركم ايضا في
ختام هذه الفقره العسكريه الخاصه بحرب
اسرائيل على غزه اعود لكم بكم الى غرفه
الاخبار والتغطيه مستمره مع وسيله c